und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
das meldet einen erneuten höchstwert bei
der inzidenz und
1571 neuinfektionen fragt sich wie
sinnvoll es noch ist sich diese zahl bis
zur letzten stelle anzusehen die
gesundheitsämter kommen nicht mehr
hinterher und viele fälle etwa an
schulen werden nicht mehr durch pcr
tests bestätigt dass derzeit etwa eine
halbe million schülerinnen und schüler
von infektionen oder quarantäne
betroffen sein sollen ist insofern auch
nur ein grober schätzwert wo stehen wir
also in dieser pandemie und wenn andere
länder trotzdem lockern dann beginnen
wir damit fragen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister gleich im
interview und bereits heute vormittag
bei der gemeinsamen pressekonferenz mit
erkern chef wähler aus berlin andreas
wehr im sternzeichen des wassermanns
geboren ist er gilt als kreativ tolerant
und freundlich als ehrgeizig und
zielstrebig lothar wieler ist wassermann
und die attribute passt
gerade in den letzten jahren gerade in
der pandemie da braucht es
durchhaltewillen und standfestigkeit
ebenso in zeiten wenn man als lka-chefin
politische ungnade gefallen ist ich habe
heute geburtstag und ich habe das glück
jetzt mit ihnen hier zusammen beim 61
geburtstag zu verbringen was denn was
kann es denn angenehm modus geben wir
sind uns doch so sehr ans herz gewachsen
insofern ist das alles in ordnung das
findet übrigens auch sein vorgesetzter
will hat man volles vertrauen sitzt ja
auch erneut ihr der gegenwind kommt von
der fdp die will wieder loswerden
mangelnde kommunikation zuletzt hatte
die reduzierung des genesenen status von
sechs auf drei monate die liberalen auf
die barrikaden gebracht
zu herrn professor villa ist alles
gesagt worden wir schauen jetzt nach
vorne
auch mit blick auf die nächste bund
länder runde denn dort müssen wir über
konkrete maßnahmen mit blick auf die
öffnungs perspektive reden ganz europa
öffnet gerade und in deutschland ist
noch nicht mal eine exit-strategie
vorhanden ach ja die öffnungs debatte
landauf landab wird über lockerungen
diskutiert viele menschen sind müde
gefrustet und wollen endlich ihr altes
vor pandemie leben zurück verständlich
doch rk ii und gesundheitsminister
bremsen
in wenigen wochen haben wir die omikron
welle überstanden bleiben wir ruhig und
achtsam und aufmerksam und dann können
wir uns entspannt auf ostern freuen wir
können also breite lockerungen wie sie
derzeit diskutiert werden zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht vertreten ich wundere
mich über die diskussion die zum teilen
der politik jetzt zu beobachten ist und
verständnis herrscht auch beim thema
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht cdu
und csu hatten gestern angekündigt die
schon gesetzlich beschlossene
impfpflicht für das personal in der
pflege und den krankenhäusern jetzt doch
nicht umsetzen zu wollen die befürchtung
dass ohnehin schon rar pflegepersonal
werde bei einer pflichtimpfung den job
quittieren
wir wollen ja alle dass wir da
vorankommen aber das wird man nicht
dadurch erreichen dass man sozusagen in
berlin ein gesetz zimmert das dann in
der praxis nicht funktioniert das
schafft verdruss und ärger
übrigens ein gesetz bei dem ein gewisser
markus söder im bundesrat kräftig mit
gezimmert hat
eigentlich haben wir keine neuen fakten
an dieser stelle von anfang an war klar
dass es natürlich auch bei der umsetzung
probleme und herausforderungen geben
würde an denen muss gearbeitet werden
aber jeder verantwortungsbewusste
politiker muss wissen dass geltendes
recht geltendes recht ist muss das als
allererstes sagen jede menge
konfliktpotenzial für die nächste bund
länder runde kommende woche das weiß
auch der gesundheitsminister und
der bundesgesundheitsminister ist uns
zugeschaltet guten abend herr lauterbach
gründe haben können sie ärgern sich
wahnsinnig über den sonderweg sage ich
mal von bayern in sachen teil
impfpflicht sind sie so sauer dass sie
auch darüber nachdenken das land bayern
zu zwingen sich an die absprachen zu
halten wir können das land bayern kaum
zwingen sich an die absprachen zu halten
ich hoffe dass es auch nicht notwendig
ist ich hoffe dass also herr söder noch
einlenkt weil wir haben ja bisher immer
gut zusammengearbeitet und hier geht es
ja um den schutz derjenigen die
besonders gefährdet sind ältere menschen
in pflegeeinrichtungen und kranke
menschen in krankenhäusern und die
müssen wir schützen aber eine richtige
wirklich mechanik hier an sie dazu
zwingen haben wir nicht ich hoffe wir
können mit der ganz normalen vernunft
noch arbeiten aber ich dachte es gibt
doch auch eine bringschuld von ländern
weil sie im bundesrat etwa einem
beschluss zugestimmt haben also sieht
das offenbar auch der präsident des
bundessozialgerichts der sagt das gesetz
ist klar das gesetz ist klares gesetz
gilt das kann auch nicht so einfach also
zurückgedreht werden aber tatsächlich
ist es möglich wenn jemand wie er das
macht also das gesetz einfach nicht
umzusetzen das gesetz ist ja nur so gut
wie es also kontrolliert wird wie es
umgesetzt wird wie es vollzogen wird und
wenn ein also bundesland signalisiert
wir kontrollieren das nicht dann wäre
natürlich die einrichtungen gar nicht
erst melden wer also nicht geimpft ist
und es gibt dann auch keinen vollzug
also dann passiert gar nichts von daher
ist das schon schwierig keine verzugs
nix ja auch wohl also das ist jedenfalls
das argument jetzt nicht nur von herrn
söder dass die gesundheitsämter dass das
gar nicht schaffen da jetzt die leute
einzeln quasi vorzuladen mit denen zu
reden und dann auch noch und in ihr
eigenes ermessen anzuwenden ob es jetzt
ein beschäftigungsverbot oder ein
betretungsverbot gibt dass das also
eigentlich vom bund auch da nicht genug
geliefert wurde wie das umzusetzen ist
dieses gesetz naja das gesetz muss
umgesetzt werden von den ländern wir
haben ja als boden keine möglichkeit
jetzt den vollzug des gesetzes im land
zu machen und man muss auch vorsichtig
sein da ist einiges also einfach
vorgeschoben es ist sehr unbeliebt
dieses gesetz umzusetzen weil die
einrichtungen natürlich darüber
hinaus also eine für eine kurze zeit
zumindest mitarbeiter verlieren das will
niemand aber das muss man halt wissen
wir machen das ja nicht als schikane
sondern wir wollen die besonders
gefährdeten leute schützen vor
infektionen und tod schutz hier geht es
nicht um eine kleinigkeit und wenn du
also gesundheitscenter zum beispiel also
dann diese listen bekommen von den
einrichtungen wer ist davon betroffen
also wer ist nicht geimpft dann kann ein
schriftliches anhörungsverfahren
stattfinden die leute müssen nicht
persönlich zunächst mehr angerührt wird
und die gesundheitsämter können das
sogar auslagern das kann zum beispiel
also
arbeitsmediziner ausgelagert werden
somit es gibt eine reihe von umsetzungs
also strategien die die länder hier
nutzen können die sagten skalierungen
die honorable und die verletzlichen also
alte menschen kranke menschen zu
schützen durch die impfung aber wir
wissen doch inzwischen dass auch
geimpfte sich anstecken können mit
omikron und auch andere dann damit
anstecken können nimmt das nicht auch
dieser impfpflicht debatte ein stück
weit die grundlage die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass jemand jemanden
ansteckt ist
einfach sehr viel geringeren erkämpft
ist also wenn ich geimpft bin ist es
erstmal sehr viel wahrscheinlicher dass
ich mich überhaupt anstecken und wenn
ich dann angesteckt bin ist es wiederum
in der regel so dass die virus lass dir
dann ausgeschieden wird also nur kurzer
zeit ausgeschieden wird somit es einfach
das risiko sich zunächst mal überhaupt
anzustecken geringer und dann jemanden
zu infizieren des geringer tun habe dass
er gemacht also wenn dann so
argumentiert dass die impfung sowieso
nichts bringt und so habe ich selbst
herrn söder nicht verstanden dass er das
also infragestellung würde zu weit geht
er dann doch nicht also wenn man so weit
gehen würde und sagte irgendwann bringt
nichts das ist natürlich eine position
die wissenschaftlichen schal preist
man nach israel blicken die haben sehr
sehr hohe zahlen deren impfquote ist
nicht höher als bei uns im gegenteil
überraschender weise sogar niedriger und
trotzdem sagen die jetzt schluss mit
diesem grünen pass und den
zugangsbeschränkungen wir lassen das
jetzt jedem selbst verantwortung zu
übernehmen warum ist das für sie für
deutschland kein weg ich habe mal
ausgerechnet wie viele menschen derzeit
also mit der strategie israels sterben
würden wenn wir ähnlich vorgehen würden
und dann kommt man auf eine also quote
von vielleicht 400 500 menschen die in
deutschland sterben würden wenn wir also
diese öffnungen zu machen würden und bei
uns sterben aber jetzt hat zwischen 100
und 150 mit 104 zu viel immer noch am
tag ihren tag immer noch zu viel aber
ich mag mir einfach gar nicht vorstellen
also dass wir in einer situation werden
so spät in der pandemie wo wir gute
impfungen haben wo wir dann 4 500 tote
am tag hätten das möchte ich einfach gar
nicht mehr vorstellen daher ist die also
ist die vorgehensweise in israel
diesbezüglich wirklich für uns nicht
vorbildlich und sie ist auch in israel
sehr umstritten aber diejenigen die
dafür argumentieren sagen auch mit con
ist milder es gibt nicht so viele
todesfälle und wer glaubt er hat ein
besonderes risiko muss dann ja
vielleicht auch nicht in den club oder
in der bar gehen also das ist die
argumentation der befürworter in israel
das sind ja oft nicht diejenigen die
dann schwer krank werden oder sterben
dem club gewesen sind sondern das sind
diejenigen die dann denjenigen begegnen
die im club gewesen sind das ist ja das
traurige also sozusagen der ältere
menschen also im leben nicht auf die
idee käme in den club zu gehen in einer
solchen situation wird dann infiziert
von jemandem der im klub gewesen ist und
die ansteckung weiter trägt und das ist
also was wir nicht wollen und die also
vorgehensweise in israel sehr riskant
weil also der schutz der älteren leute
nicht wirklich ausreicht um so viel zu
öffnen wie man das derzeit beobachtet
noch mal zurück nach deutschland sind
sie nach wie vor sicher dass die welle
bis ostern brecht
ich bin sehr sicher dass die welle bis
ostern brich ich glaube sogar dass wir
also in den nächsten zwei oder drei
wochen
so eine stabilisierung der vater sehen
und dass es dann herunter gehen konnte
ich warne davor dass wir zu früh öffnen
aber wenn wir klug sind was wir
geschafft haben das wesen im
wesentlichen wir haben die omikron welle
von mitte januar bis jetzt eigentlich so
also geschützt gefahren dass wir gegeben
dass wir so viele ältere menschen haben
und dass wir soviel ungeimpfte eltern
haben wir alle also relativ niedrige
sterberate gab das ist eine auswahl sich
leistung man muss ja auch der
bevölkerung sagen weshalb machen wir das
alles wir haben hier wirklich erfolg
also es nicht perfekt gewesen aber
deutlich weniger todesfälle als sonst zu
erwarten gewesen wären wenn wir jetzt
schlau sind und nehmen die maßnahmen
nicht so schnell weg riskieren also
keinen rückfall lassen die welle
einbrechen was ab ende mitte/ende
februar passieren würde dann kommen wir
durch diese welle gut durch und wenn wir
dann noch die allgemeine impfpflicht
schaffen dann werden wir sogar für einen
rückfall im herbst vorbereitet mal sehen
ob das mit der impfpflicht kommt herr
lauterbach ich danke für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen
das interview haben wir am früheren
abend geführt nachher im heute schon mal
update gibt es noch ein interview mit
dem intensivpfleger ricardo lange über
die situation in seinem berufsstand
das war schon ein ziemlicher
paukenschlag als us präsident joe biden
gestern klipp und klar sagte wenn
russlands die ukraine angreift dann gibt
es kein nord stream zwei end of
discussion der deutsche bundeskanzler
stand daneben und sagte billig er
widersprach aber auch nicht den nachhall
wird man bis nach mecklenburg vorpommern
gehört haben sowie allgemein in der spd
in der es ja große vorbehalte gibt putin
mit der gaspipeline zu drohen ein grund
mehr warum die ampel regierung nur
hoffen kann dass der kreml sich in der
ukraine zurück hält die abgründe in die
die welt sonst blicken würde während
tief und klar auch was der parallele
besuch makros in moskau gebracht hat
dann der pflanzen berichtet
wenn es schon etwas olaf scholz iges
gibt der kommunikation des kanzlers olaf
scholz etwas herausstechen typisches
also dann wohl dies dass etwa oft nicht
genau sagt was er vorhat wohl aber dass
es das notwendige sein werde das gute
das richtige ein wenig davon auch heute
abend an der seite von angie du da und
immer nur im agro unser bestreben heute
im rahmen des weimarer dreiecks
wir wollen für eine deeskalation der aus
hass angespannten lage sorgen wir
brauchen verhandlungen und eine lösung
und auch mit blick auf seine reise nach
kiew und moskau nächste woche unser
austausch zu diesem zeitpunkt wird daher
ganz besonders gewinnbringend sein denn
uns alle eint ein ziel den frieden in
europa zu erhalten
deeskalation und europäische
geschlossenheit darauf komme es nun
zentral an betonten alle drei dafür der
derzeitige diplomatie marathon
präsident emanuel marco war gestern in
moskau herr bundeskanzler hat sich mit
präsident biden ausgetauscht und ich bin
gestern aus peking zurückgekommen wo ich
mich mit präsident jean ping
ausgetauscht habe seit ich wieder auf es
seien bei alldem neuer ansätze
entstanden in den letzten tagen ergänzte
makro daran wolle man weiter arbeiten
und den anspruchsvollen dialog mit
russland fortsetzen unter einhaltung der
eigenen grundsätze werte und
geschlossenheit
eben jene geschlossenheit die in diesen
tagen also einen wert an sich darstellt
war tags zuvor auch in washington
demonstriert worden und das obwohl
beiden das projekt nord stream 2 im
falle eines russischen ein maß für tot
erklärte während olaf scholz schon den
begriff nord stream zwei vermied in
bekannter diktion
wir werden diese schritte auch alle
notwendigen schritte ergreifen und sie
können sicher sein es wird auch keine
maßnahmen geben bei denen wir
unterschiedlicher agiert intern server
was die kritik in den us medien angeht
deutschland seien nicht verlässlich
deutschland ist absolut verlässlich an
deutschland habe ich nicht den
geringsten zweifel
es waren gleichwohl nicht nur us medien
sondern auch us-abgeordnete die zuvor
eben diese zweifel geäußert hatten beim
versuch sie zu zerstreuen in einer
durchaus nicht alltäglichen
medienoffensive wurde scholz dann
ungewohnt deutlich etwa zum vorwurf
deutschland werde in osteuropa immer
stärker als alliierte russlands denn als
alliierter des westens angesehen
konsens sei das so scholz als mit den
usa größter geldgeber der ukraine habe
man sofort sind zwei milliarden dollar
gegeben
bei vielen diesseits und jenseits des
atlantiks bleibt dennoch die frage nach
dem warum warum dieses nicht konkrete
gerade mit blick auf 0 2 rückendeckung
für scholz aus seiner partei auch von
einem der bislang nicht als freund des
rhetorisch ungefähren galt und auf
scholz hat von vornherein klar gemacht
wir werden nicht erkennen lassen welche
sanktionsmöglichkeiten in welcher
gewichtung oder reihenfolge zum zuge
kommen und das ist auch wichtig wenn man
in einer starken verhandlungsposition
gegenüber putin sein möchte dass er
nicht vorher eine kosten
folgenabschätzung vornehmen kann es
klingt fast ein wenig olaf scholz ich
was der spd generalsekretär der sagt das
notwendige tun das richtige was genau
aber aus guten gründen offen
derweil ist außenministerin baerbock
weiter auf diplomatische mission in der
ukraine
ihre aufgabe besteht vor allem darin der
ukrainischen regierung die solidarität
deutschlands zu versichern und den
ukrainern gleichzeitig zu erklären warum
in berlin aber nicht alles liefert was
ich dir wünschst geld und helme jahr
waffen nein
heute war sie im osten des landes dort
wo man den mächtigen russischen nachbarn
hautnah spüren
so sieht die verletzung der ukraine aus
über die diplomatie seit acht jahren
spricht die verletzung der territorialen
integrität inmitten des landes inmitten
europas der letzte check point vor der
front die groteske weise kontakt linie
heißt ab hier liegt die delegation aus
deutschland
splitterschutzwesten an in der ost
ukraine eine halbe stunde hinter mario
pohl werden nicht nur verträge und
grenzen verletzt sondern auch menschen
dann steht die deutsche außenministerin
im dörfchen chirac ihnen das mal ein
ferienort war und nun laut dem abkommen
von minsk niemandsland ist die
ukrainischen kräfte haben die
separatisten 2015 vertrieben
1900 meter land gewinn
berbalk sagt praktische unterstützung zu
ausbildung krankenbehandlung minen
vernichtung dass deutschland keine
waffen liefern will ist hier natürlich
bekannt aber jede hilfe willkommen
ich tue alles dafür dass menschen hier
in europa und wir sind hier mitten in
europa in frieden leben können und das
bedeutet dass wir sehr sehr deutlich
machen jede weitere aggression hätte
massive folgen für die russische seite
weil das wichtigste für die menschen ist
frieden vielen dank
während berbalk die pro ukrainische
seite der kontakt linie besucht manche
wünsche erfüllt und manche enttäuscht
ist ein zdf team auf der pro-russischen
in der donezker volksrepublik dnr die
von russland unterstützten separatisten
nehmen sehr genau wahr wie entschlossen
wie grundsätzlich einig der westen zur
ukraine steht auch in bonn jetzt wird um
waffen um hilfe gebeten
russland unterstützt uns wirtschaftlich
russland unterstützt uns auf humanitärem
gebiet ohne russland wäre es schlecht
aber ich persönlich hätte schon gern
dass russland seine truppen einrücken
lässt dann würde der krieg aufhören
zurück zu den deutschen an der kontakt
linie auge und ohr der internationalen
gemeinschaft soll die osze seien aber
russland verweigert den beobachtern
zugang etwa zur krim von einer
radikalisierung auf beiden seiten
berichten sie berbalk der
waffenstillstand hält nicht nur
deswegen bin ich hier und genau deswegen
arbeite ich tagtäglich mit
internationalen partnern daran dass wir
in den unterschiedlichen kontaktgruppen
dazu kommen dass der waffenstillstand
eingehalten wird und dass wir vor allen
dingen dazu kommen das menschen
irgendwann wieder in frieden in der
region leben können für donnerstag ist
der nächste kontakt zwischen
ukrainischen und russischen diplomaten
geplant in berlin ohne allzu viel
hoffnung
einer reportage von andreas künast er
die ministerin die ukraine begleitet hat
und jetzt eins mit anderen nachrichten
des tages der frühere papst benedikt der
sechzehnte hat in einem brief zum
missbrauchsskandal
und freising stellung genommen er bittet
die opfer sexualisierter gewalt um
entschuldigung und spricht von tiefer
scham und großem schmerz den er empfinde
zugleich wehrt sich benedikt gegen den
vorwurf als münchner erzbischof
missbrauchsfälle vertuscht zu haben bei
seiner einlassung zu dem ende januar
veröffentlichten gutachten aber erst mal
einen fehler gemacht nicht aber
getäuscht oder belogen betroffene
reagierten mit enttäuschung auf die
stellungnahme
die mindestlöhne für die beschäftigten
in der altenpflege sollen ab september
in mehreren schritten angehoben werden
das bundesarbeits und das
bundesgesundheitsministerium teilt mit
darauf habe sich die zuständige
pflegekommission geeinigt bis ende 2023
sollen die mindestlöhne für hilfskräfte
von 12 auf 14 euro 15 steigen für
qualifizierte hilfskräfte von 12 50 auf
15 eur 25 für pflegefachkräfte von 15
auf 18 eur
25 der urlaubsanspruch soll ab 2023 auf
29 tage im jahr steigen
außenministerin berbalk holt die chefin
von greenpeace die us-amerikanerin
jennifer morgen in ihr ministerium erst
als sonderbeauftragte für klima
die umweltorganisation wwf warnt
anlässlich einer neuen studie des
alfred-wegener-instituts vor einer
plastizität der weltmeere die
verschmutzung der gewässer durch plastik
nehme mit bis zu 23 millionen tonnen pro
jahr mittlerweile ein bedrohliches
ausmaß an kurz vor dem anstehenden un
umweltgipfel in nairobi fordert der wwf
ein verbindliches globales abkommen um
die verschmutzung einzudämmen
trotz seiner strikten null co wird
politik breitet sich das corona virus in
hong kong aus lange gab es in der 7
millionen metropole so gut wie keine
infektionen ende dezember sollen zwei
flugbegleiterinnen das virus
eingeschleppt haben heute wurden 6 125
fälle registriert regierungschefin lahm
kündigte weitere beschränkungen an in
der öffentlichkeit dürften sich maximal
zwei personen treffen und neben
schließungen in vielen anderen bereichen
seien nun auch kirchen oder
friseurbesuche nicht mehr erlaubt
zu den vielen erkenntnissen der korona
pandemie gehört ja auch wie empfindlich
internationalen lieferketten durch ein
solches weltereignis getroffen werden
aus asien kam erstmal deutlich weniger
und das betraf nicht nur dringend
benötigte medizinische masken die vor
allem dort produziert werden
aktuell macht der europäischen
wirtschaft einen mangel an mikrochips
beziehungsweise halbleitern zu schaffen
und auch da merken die europäer wie
abhängig sie von asien und den usa sind
das soll sich ändern berichtet anne
gellinek
genau davon träumt die eu eine nagelneue
chipfabrik von intel in ohio eine 20
milliarden dollar investition eröffnet
ende januar in den usa intel sucht auch
einen standort in europa deutschland
macht sich hoffnungen vielleicht nicht
umsonst damit amerikanische noch besser
asiatische marktführer in europa chip
fabriken bauen hat die eu heute einen
großen schritt getan
findet jedenfalls die eu-kommission
selbst der französische industrie
kommissar thierry breton hält einen
riesen chip mit haarfeinen gravuren hoch
wie zum beweis europa kann das
wir haben immer gedacht die zukunft ist
dass wir in europa keine fabriken mehr
brauchen hier das labor dort die fabrik
aber bei den halbleitern ist das falsch
wir brauchen beides laborunfall blick
vom laptop nennen wir das
elf milliarden euro frisches geld dazu
32 milliarden aus bestehenden programmen
will die kommission in den nächsten
jahren locker machen um chip produzenten
mit subventionen zu ködern schon bald
sollen 20 prozent der chips aus europa
kommen und nicht 9 wie jetzt spätestens
die pandemie hat allen gezeigt wie
abhängig europa ist das wenn in asien
ein hafen wegen quarantäne schließt bei
deutschen autoherstellern die montage
straßen ins stocken geraten ohne mikro
chips läuft nichts sie stecken überall
drin und kommen aus regionen die
geopolitisch umkämpft sind wie taiwan
der chips act ist also der versuch
europa unabhängiger zu machen
erwachsener selbstständige auch der
versuch die globalisierung ein stück
zurück zu drehen
der traum dass man wirklich
durch handel eben weltweit vorteile
nutzen kann vielleicht auch noch
demokratie und so weiter fördern kann
und dass man dann einen gegenseitigen
vorteil unterwegs ist der ist glaube ich
ein bisschen ausgeträumt also harte
bandagen europa versucht mit china und
den usa mitzuhalten subventionen
auszuschütten und wettbewerbsregeln zu
lockern und das sonst so kritische
europaparlament findet das genau richtig
selbst abgeordnete aus ländern die mit
steuergeld eigentlich
die halbleiterindustrie ist keine
normale branche es geht hauptsächlich um
geopolitik das bedeutet dass sich alle
staaten bemühen und einmischen und wenn
europa das nicht tut spielen wir nicht
mehr mit europa also mischt sich ein
versucht mit den großen mitzuspielen der
slogan vom parlament ist wie für den
chips act gemacht die zukunft liegt in
euren händen
mit dem thema geht es jetzt auch an der
börse noch mal weiter ja die initiative
für ein milliardenschweres europäisches
engagement ist nun also da die ziele
sind gesteckt wie stehen die chancen
dass sie auch erreicht werden bei der
reha die eu wird sich ganz schön
strecken müssen um mit der konkurrenz
mitzuhalten kritiker meinen dass der zug
schon längst abgefahren sein könnte bis
die ersten europäischen chips aus der eu
initiative vom band laufen vergehen
schließlich noch jahre außerdem stecken
die amerikaner und die asiaten zum teil
erheblich mehr geld in die
chipentwicklung zum vergleich 43
milliarden euro will die eu in den
nächsten jahren investieren bescheiden
im vergleich zu china da sind es 132
milliarden euro die europäische
subventionspolitik hat nicht nur mehr
versorgungssicherheit zum ziel sondern
auch technologische führerschaft das
geld soll ship hersteller nach europa
locken und so die eu unabhängiger machen
denn der chip mangel hat die industrie
ausgebremst das soll nicht noch mal
passieren vor allem da künftig immer
mehr halbleiter gebraucht werden
beispiel autoindustrie
heute werden chips im wert von 650 euro
pro auto verbaut in den kommenden vier
jahren werden es schon
875 euro sein die eu will aber nicht nur
mehr chips in europa produzieren lassen
werden die halbleiter mal wieder knapp
will sie im extremfall sogar
exportbeschränkungen das gab es zwar
schon mal im umgang mit corona
impfstoffen in der wirtschaft wäre das
aber ein zeitenwandel hinzu fast schon
einer gesinnung europe fast alle real
vielen dank
der gründer der drogeriekette dm götz
werner ist gestorben im alter von 78
jahren werner eröffnete 1973 in
karlsruhe seinen ersten selbstbedienungs
drogeriemarkt fast 4000 märkte hat dass
die mmp rium inzwischen werner setzte
sich neben seinem engagement als
unternehmer unter anderem auch für ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen ein
bundespräsident steinmeier hat den
dirigenten sir simon rattle mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz geehrt der
langjährige chefdirigent der berliner
philharmoniker sei ein hochverdienter
künstler und teamspieler so steinmeier
bei der verleihung rattle hatte das
orchester noch einmal ganz neu dem
publikum geöffnet derzeit ist rattle in
london tätig habe dem kommenden jahr
solle die leitung des
symphonieorchesters des bayerischen
rundfunks übernehmen
der frühere papst benedikt hat sich
heute ja zum missbrauchsskandal in der
katholischen kirche geäußert dazu passt
die 37° -reportage gleich im anschluss
die sicht von betroffenen zeigt um 0.45
gibt es dann also heute schneller
abstellt bitten dass anpackte mir und
uns geht es dann morgen wieder
[Musik]
guten abend wenn sie ganz genau
hinschauen dann sehen sie hier den
wolkenfreien bereich in der mitte dieses
tiefdruck wirbels aber diese tiefdruck
wirbel die langsam nach osten ziehen
haben für uns auch tatsächlich bedeutung
hier in mitteleuropa
denn diese wolken schleppe die reicht
nach mitteleuropa und noch hinaus auf
den atlantik so wird es heute nacht also
norddeutschland regnen im süden ist es
zum teil klar und am alpenrand sinken
die temperaturen über schnee bis auf
minus sechs grad im norden bleibt die
nacht milder bei 8 bis 5 grad und morgen
wird ein sehr milder februartag mit
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 7 und 14
grad und ähnlich wie heute ist es auch
morgen in norddeutschland eher bedeckten
das fällt regen zwischen dem emsland und
der ostseeküste richtung süden sind die
wolken dagegen etwas lockerer und am
strahlendsten scheint die sonne zwischen
dem allgäu und dem oberrhein da können
durchaus die astronomische möglichen
neuen knapp zehn sonnenstunden zusammen
kommen richtung norddeutschland sieht
das anders aus das aber wird sich ändern
bis samstag da erwarten uns doch in ganz
deutschland meist fünf bis neun
sonnenstunden nur in norddeutschland
bleibt es zum teil auch etwas trüber am
donnerstag ändert sich als unserem
wetter erstmal wenig der regen zieht
etwas weiter richtung süden bei 6 bis 13
grad am freitag gibt es dann schnee
schnee regen und graupelschauer
vielleicht sogar einzelne gewitter bei 2
bis 8 grad am samstag sind die gewitter
dadurch und es wird für fast alle
richtig sonnig guten abend